[Music]
so what I do somebody was I'm loading
him oh right there he's on that arm
Oh what's over again so when I step home
emits the arm I don't don't just roll as
you okay so if all like it is the kazoo
she can walk out of it he should he
should walk out
you think he's always time to walk out
of it you get it every time if you're
gonna find it you're gonna go through
the wall go down okay but that's what
he's trying to do and you're gonna get a
better sense of of what's happening okay
let's go so this one will be he's just
gonna fly at me like that with one hand
whoa okay but the idea so this is that
ham but a little differently so he goes
I'm just gonna move and he'll throw
himself he goes
okay let's get there survive I want that
coming in hey this had happened
not by me moving his arm left to run by
me moving to maintain zero pressure it's
the same thing here he comes in I'm not
easy reflection I'll go like this
that's a clash they say comes in and
your zero question comes if zero
friendship in other Highness a party
we're not doing this just getting out of
the way taking pressure off
okay my job wait wait hey he can run
through if he wants that's the matter
you gonna try to not take the blood of
it by going under it but this arm is
doing the same thing this time his face
boom hit stuff grandpa yeah there's
creditor
so it's not just my arm hitting the base
Shortbus
watch me
punch my face
okay let's check but watch the gang had
a reconciliation
watch my spotting the plank where does
it go forward Young had watch my hip
turn
way to achieve together throws this
punch you see where I'm going get
yourself inside boom once I get inside
deflect your punch would be right where
my head was right hits me in the head
it'd be hard harder faster faster faster
Oh weird weird ass weird isn't it okay
so we'll try it again
I go inside yeah I go inside the punch
he's thing he's gonna hit me with his on
okay once I feel them boom
I do the coke cute and not going like
this go in here coke you
okay let's go